[Musik]
ich bin mario leopold wegscheider und
habe die ehre sie als moderator bei der
angelobung von 77 soldaten des stabs
card alliance 3 und das jägerbataillon
19 begleiten und durch den militärischen
fest sagt führen zu dürfen in kürze
erfolgt die meldung durch den
kommandanten der ausgerückten truppe
herr hauptmann raesfeld rittern an den
regalen komponenten der dritten
jägerbrigade regale schnelle kräfte
herrn brigadier christian habersatter
darauf folgt die bundeshymne und im
anschluss an die bundeshymne wird der
brigade kommandant gemeinsam mit dem
bataillons komponenten herr oberst georg
ertinger die front abschreiten
unmittelbar daran erfolgt die große
flaggenparade
[Musik]
herr hauptmann krieg haben meldet gegen
den sieger der gruppe stadtviertels 3
und der compagnie mit dem einrichtungs
termin mai 2020 zur angelobung
angetreten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die sonst langsam
[Musik]
ich darf nun das wort an den kommunen
die staatsbad 13 oberst dirk ertinger
für die begrüßungsworte übergeben und im
anschluss folgt ein choral geschätzte
damen und herren es ist mir trotz corona
eine große freude sie heute als
bataillons genannt zur angelobung einer
etwas anderen art begrüßen zu dürfen
sehen sie diesen tag als ihren festtag
internet bewegenden momente während
ihrer zeit beim österreichischen
bundesheer sie werden auch in zukunft
gerne an diesem tag zurückblicken
heute werden sie ihr treuegelöbnis
spüren unter normalen umständen wäre das
im zuge eines öffentlichen festaktes
vollzogen worden
inmitten von hunderten gästen ihren
familien und bekannten ihren freundinnen
und freunden
aufgrund der gesamtheitlichen lage ist
das jedoch nicht in dieser form möglich
nur wenigen auserwählten ist es
gestattet an diesem festakt teilzunehmen
und so darf ich in unserer ehrengäste
nutzer mieter hier herzlich willkommen
heißen
ein besonderer gruß gilt unseren brigade
komponenten herrn brigadier magister
christian habersatter willkommen in
weiterer beim start million
ein herzliches grüß gott den vertretern
des klerus herrn militärdekan magister
magister doktor doktor alexander wessel
danke für die anreise aus dem burgenland
und herren militär senior magister
michael altinger herzlich willkommen
für die garnison weiter entwickle ich
meinen gruß man herrn spitze leutnant
wolfgang ein anderer kommunaler betrieb
staffel oder coolen ringer kaserne in
vertretung für den garnisonskommandanten
sowie an den vorsitzenden des
dienststellen ausschusses herren spitze
leuten an peter kein speziell aber darf
ich sie an zuge lebende rekruten des
einrücken turnus mai 2020 begrüßen sie
die in einer doch sehr herausfordernden
zeit ihren grundwehrdienst angetreten
haben sie diese für die aus ableistung
des grundwehrdienstes entschieden haben
und nun ihren ersten abschnitt ihrer
ausbildung bei der kompanie des
bataillons 3 erfolgreich abgeschlossen
haben
ich konnte mich in den vergangenen
wochen von ihrem einsatzwillen und der
hohen motivation im zuge der
dienstaufsicht überzeugen
im persönlichen gespräch insbesondere
mit jenen welche die garagen als ihre
unterkunft in den letzten wochen hatten
habe ich erfahren dass sie sehr rasch
mit den herausfordernden einschränkungen
aufgrund des corona virus umzugehen
gelernt haben ihre kommandanten und
ausbilder verfügen großteils über sehr
lange erfahrung im bereich der
ausbildung unter führung von soldaten
sie haben die ausbildung unter
berücksichtigung der verschärften
bestimmungen so gut als eben möglich
durchgeführt
dazu gilt ihnen ihr persönlicher dank
sie geschätzte rekruten werden mit dem
morgigen tag zu anderen dienststellen
des bundesheeres versetzt sie werden in
weiterer folge ins system erhalten
funktionen ihren dienst versehen
sei es in einer der kirchen oder
betreuungseinrichtungen oder
darstellungs straße des militärkommandos
als kraftfahrer oder wachsoldat ihre
tätigkeit ist wichtig und bildet die
grundlage für einen geordneten
dienstbetrieb des österreichischen
bundesheeres
sie werden während ihrer zeit als soldat
viel erleben ausbildungen über sich
ergehen lassen
teile von ihnen vielleicht einen einsatz
bewältigen oder dienst schieben müssen
sie werden kameradschaft erleben sie
werden neue freunde kennenlernen
behalten sie dabei auch das stadion 3
insbesondere aber die leher komponieren
weiter in guter erinnerung
ich wünsche ihnen für ihre zeit beim
österreichischen bundesheer alles gute
und vor allem aber dass sie nach sechs
monaten wieder gesund und voll start in
das zivile leben zurückkehren können
üblicherweise steht am beginn jeder
angelobung die begrüßung durch den
bürgermeister
derzeit ist das nicht möglich er hat
mehr warb der bürgermeister von dieser
stadt gemeinde weiter hier eine
grußbotschaft für sie sehr geehrte
rekruten übermittelt die ich ihnen jetzt
zur kenntnis bringen möchte sehr geehrte
skater personal liebe rekruten die
angelobung ist zweifelsohne eine der
höhepunkte des grundwehrdienstes was
oftmals als festtag mit
familienangehörigen und besuchern sowie
ehrengästen aus politik wirtschaft und
des öffentlichen lebens abgehalten wird
muss diesmal ohne zuseher ausgerichtet
werden
ich freue mich dennoch sehr dass ich die
möglichkeit bekomme einige worte an euch
zu richten
die aufgaben und die dafür notwendigen
finanziellen mitteln des
österreichischen bundesheeres wurde in
der vergangenen zeit oft diskutiert
besonders bei den katastrophen einsetzen
der letzten jahre sind die
hilfeleistungen des bundesheeres 1
unverzichtbarer bestandteil gewesen der
ohne die hilfe der soldaten nicht zu
schaffen gewesen wäre
gerade aber die aktuelle situation ist
für jeden von uns vor wenigen monaten
noch undenkbar gewesen
eine situation in welcher von der
regierung innerhalb weniger tage sehr
wichtige entscheidungen getroffen werden
mussten und bevölkerung zu schützen und
die versorgung sicherzustellen
die soldatinnen und soldaten des
bundesheeres leisten jetzt gerade mit
ihrer tätigkeit in
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz im zusammenhang mit 19
bei der unterstützung der polizei zur
überwachung der grünen grenze sowie der
allgemeinen hilfeleistung entlang der
niederösterreichischen grenze zu
tschechien und der slowakei einen
wesentlichen beitrag zur sicherheit und
zum schutz der bevölkerung besonders in
unseren renz regionen
ihr seid auch in den letzten wochen und
monaten bei gestanden als es darum
gegangen ist
die lebensgrundlagen der bevölkerung zu
unterstützen sowie die kritische
infrastruktur zu schützen
damit hat auch jetzt wieder das
österreichische bundesheer bewiesen dass
es eine staatliche einsatzorganisation
ist die aufgaben übernehmen muss wo
andere mittel nicht mehr ausreichen wenn
man auch in zukunft auf diese
unterstützung zählen will dann müssen
eben die notwendigen finanziellen mittel
dafür zur verfügung gestellt werden
er gehörte an zu geloben
ich möchte mich bei euch bedanken dass
ihr durch die entscheidung den
grundwehrdienst beim österreichischen
bundes jahr abzuleisten euch jener
organisation unseres staates zur
verfügung gestellt habt die dort hilft
wo andere nicht mehr können
ich wünsche euch viel freude eine schöne
zeit in unserer organisation stadt und
eine beliebte kameradschaft beim
österreichischen bundesheer gezeichnet
bürgermeister patrick mayer
[Musik]
ich darf nun die geistlichkeit herr
militärdekan magister magister doktor
doktor alexander wessel und militärs
sehen ist welche leitinger um ihre worte
bieten anschließend hören wir den smart
repair oberst geschütze kameraden aller
dienstgrade und funktionen
vor allem aber lieber an zu geloben die
kameraden
ich werde als militärpfarrer oft gefragt
ob es engel gibt und als militärpfarrer
kann ich das natürlich nur bestätigen
denn es ist die lehre der kirche und
vielleicht nennen der manche von euch
seine freundin ebenso vielleicht hat
auch mancher der vor kurzem papa
geworden ist sich gedacht der hat seinen
enkel gerade in der hand vielleicht der
herr hauptmann vor zweieinhalb monaten
und auch ein junger kamerad aus
eisenstadt ist vor zwei tagen papa
geworden und auch ein junger für sie aus
güssing ist vor zwei tagen papa geworden
und er hat sich vielleicht dasselbe
gedacht also engeln gibt es gibt die
engeln die die andenkenläden der
wallfahrtsorte bevölkern wir werden
letzte woche in lord gewesen und dort
gibt es schutzengeln on mars weil
einfach der mensch das bedürfnis nach
schutz und hilfe hat und es gibt nicht
nur die engelhaften wesen wir uns
begleiten und die wir uns nicht erklären
können wie wir uns in unseren leben so
vieles nicht erklären können
es gibt eben auch die engel mit zwei
füßen 2 hinten und einen klaren verstand
und ihr seid so wie viele andere
kameradinnen und kameraden des
bundesheeres in dieser zeit
wahrscheinlich so engeln für viele
geschützt und hilft wo andere nicht mehr
schützen und nicht mehr helfen können
egal in welcher funktion er seine energy
marke sie verspricht uns dass wir wenn
wir sie trinken
flügeln bekommen engel brauchen nicht
unbedingt flügel und ihr seid der beste
beweis dafür
und deswegen möchte ich euch für euren
einsatz beim österreichischen bundesheer
danken und ihr könnt diesen einsatz als
dienst am nächsten auch als gottesdienst
verstehen im weitesten sinne
egal wie ihr euren gott nennt sucht und
verehrt ich sage euch ein herzliches
vergelt's gott dafür und klammer auf den
versprochenen energy drink vom
unterrichten gibt es nachher natürlich
wobei vielleicht heute ein glühwein
geschickter wäre
herzlichen dank und herzliches vergelt's
gott gottes segen für euren einsatz
geschätzte rekruten liebe kameraden
wir möchten für euch und euren dienst
den ihr tut an der gesellschaft an den
menschen dieses landes auch um gottes
segen bitten herr unser gott
wir bitten dich für diese jungen
menschen dass ihre zeit beim bundesheer
nicht als verlorene zeit erleben sondern
als eine zeit da sie hineinwachsen in
die größere gemeinschaft da sie reifen
an erfahrung und charakter bewahren sie
vor unfällen und allem übel stehen bei
in not und anfechtungen lasse sie echte
kameradschaft finden untereinander mit
achtung und respekt begegnen und uns
allen schenke deinen frieden denn diese
welt so nötig hat so bitten wir dich um
deinen segen für diese jungen menschen
und ihre familien und so segne und
behüte euch der allmächtige gott armen
[Musik]
es wird nun der kommandant der dritte
jägerbrigade brigade schnell kräfte herr
brigadier magister christian h was seine
worte an sie richten danach hören wir
den marsch o du mein österreich hohe
geistlichkeit solcher terrorist
geschützte angehörige der garnison
weiter aber vor allem geschützte
rekruten vom entwicklungs termin mai
normalerweise finden an gelungen die
öffentlichkeit statt
im kreise der familie angehörigen
freunde
leider ist es ihnen nicht vergönnt und
wir stehen hier relativ alleine unter
einhaltung der sogenannten cupid
schutzmaßnahmen
so wird der virus ein unsichtbarer
gegner der seit anfang des jahres europa
aber auch mittlerweile die ganze welt in
atem hielt über fünf millionen personen
infiziert und an die 350.000 menschen
die leider schon im zusammenhang mit
diesem virus ihr leben verloren haben
und der grund für eine angelobung in der
öffentlichkeit ist das ein besonderes
verhältnis
ein bund eine beziehung eingegangen wird
mit der republik österreich und diese
beziehung ist eine besondere
sie treten sozusagen als zivilist jetzt
offiziell in den dienst als soldat im
bundesheer zu leisten dienst an der
bevölkerung und das ist eine beziehung
die sie ganzes leben eingegangen sind
eine besondere beziehung
es ist kein verein
es ist auch nicht eine sonstige
organisation es ist bewaffnete macht
österreichs die einen zweck hat nämlich
die militärische landesverteidigung und
wie sie wissen gibt es ja auch gewisse
anforderungen an soldaten aber auch die
möglichkeit dass man hier im einsatz
leider verletzt oder sogar mehr werden
kann
und sie treten auch aus meiner sicht ein
in eine große familie die sich eben
bundesheer nennt und dieser moment und
diese familie wird sie auf längere zeit
in erinnerung halten oder in erinnerung
bleiben
auch ich selbst kann mich noch erinnern
an meinen tag der angelobung es war 1988
in salzburg am residenzplatz und ich
gehe davon aus dass auch sie diesen tag
ein guter erinnerung haben werden sie
haben während ihrer ersten wochen beim
bundesheer sehr viel ausbildung erlebt
das war zum einen handwerkliche
ausbildung aber auch wurden in
verschiedenen werten mitgegeben werte
wie kameradschaft disziplin gehorsam zu
verlässlichkeit pünktlichkeit und vieles
mehr
und ich kann es kann sie nur suchen
diese werte konsequent weiter zu
verfolgen
das sind werte die auch in unserer
gesellschaft wieder an wert gewonnen
haben und gerade co wird verlangt von
uns kameradschaft auch im zivilen leben
jemanden anderen nicht zu durch solchen
verlässlichkeit disziplin
das hat einstein stellenwert gewonnen
und ein guter begriff von diesen werten
haben sie von ihren ausbildern
mitbekommen und sie werden gehen in neue
funktionen und ich kann sie nur suchen
hier
diese werte auch weiter zu leben
zu verfolgen damit wird ihnen
unterstützung gegeben auch in erfüllung
ihrer aufgabe beim österreichischen
bundesheer egal wie diese aufgabe in
zukunft auch sein wird ob sie verwendet
werden als weiß sobald das fahrer alles
sanitäter oder ähnliches jeder leistet
seinen beitrag zur funktionalität und
zum funktionieren des bundesheeres
ich vergleiche das immer mit anderen
organisationen in einer bank kann nicht
jeder am schalter sitzen und das
geldzählen ausgeben oder was auch immer
es gibt viele die dazu erforderlich sind
den bankangestellten die arbeit zu
ermöglichen oder bei der feuerwehr kann
nicht jeder am feuerwehrfahrzeug
ausrücken um irgendwo in eine person aus
einem fahrzeug zu retten es braucht
viele helfende unterstützende
organisierende hand im hintergrund und
diese aufgaben sind ernst zu nehmen und
freuen sie sich auf ihre zukünftigen
aufgaben geschätzte gut nicht wünsche
ihnen dazu in ihrer neuen funktion auch
alles gute ich möchte aber auch die
gelegenheit wahrnehmen um mich beim
kaderpersonal zu bedanken
dieser grundwehrdienst für die kameraden
hätte eigentlich in güssing stattfinden
sollen wird hier in weiterer
durchgeführt noch die nächsten tage
ich danke dem kaderpersonal für den
weiteren weg vom den herrn aus güssing
ich danke allen die auch hier in der
garnison teil sind für ihren beitrag
damit dass die kameraden entsprechend
ausgebildet werden können und ein
rüstzeug für die nächsten schritt
bekommen haben geschätzte rekruten
nehmen sie ihre aufgabe ernst leben sie
diese werte und nehmen sie die sache
ernst denn es ihr dienst dienst der
gesellschaft der österreichischen
bevölkerung unserem land und dieser
republik
ich danke ihnen
[Musik]
nun erfolgt der höhepunkt des festaktes
die feierliche angelobung der 77
rekruten des eindrucks termines mai 2020
gute sprecht mir lag ich glaube mein
vaterland die republik weißt du es gut
sein volk zu schützen
unser häuschen und mit der waffe zu
verteidigen
ich gelobe ich glaube den gesetzen und
den gesetzmäßigen behörden bürger selbst
treue und gehorsam zu leisten
treue und gehorsam zu leisten alle
befehle meiner vorgesetzten
möglichst genau zu befolgen möglich und
genau zu befolgen und mit allen meinen
kräften und mitarbeiter der republik
österreich
[Applaus]
es erklingt nun die landeshymne im
anschluss daran bietet der kombi nannte
ausgerückten truppe regale komponenten
um weitere befehle
[Musik]
[Applaus]